[Music]
oh hey there welcome to the brand new
season 10 big brother canada house it is
glossy it is shiny it is sexy it is
everything you need to represent the
greatest game on earth let's go
[Music]
over 180 000 feet of video and audio
cable 22 kilometers of led tape we're
talking 20 000 man hours for this build
so we wanted the house to make you feel
like you were inside a game show whether
it be retro or modern and i mean come on
does anything scream more classic game
show than this wheel right here because
trust and believe we will be leaving the
house guests heads spinning
our houses really are like these living
breathing entities and this year more
than ever it was purpose built for the
twists tasks and challenges coming your
way this season like all of these
mystery doors what secrets lie behind
them
it's going to take all season for you
and the house guests to find out
now if you've ever seen big brother
canada before you know so much goes down
in the bathroom because it basically is
one of the only rooms in the house that
every single player has an excuse to be
in so i guarantee you sparks are gonna
fly right here
so this is the diary room where you
really do get to fall in love with house
guests because of course this is where
they are safe to talk about their most
intimate thoughts and their game
theories
and think back to all of your favorite
players over the years chances are they
gave really good diary room
[Music]
oh i love this one come on check out the
new hoh room
now aside from the power this room right
here is why you want to be head of
household we are really feeling our 70s
fantasy with this one from the velvet to
the shag
to the crystal to these hot hot colors
and these gorgeous sequined letters i
mean come on couldn't you picture a head
of household trying to figure out how to
take over the game or take over the
world
this house has over 100 cameras over 100
microphones and a million secrets
including what's in this room
[Applause]
[Music]
well there you have it the season 10
house the game within a game within a
game and the one last thing we wanted to
show you was this giant 32 by 16 foot
video wall behind us
something we added to just remind these
brave house guests exactly what they're
playing for
all right back to you guys
[Music]